well covet quarantine has been an
extraordinary uh productive period for
president joe biden and i'm not kidding
around i mean think back to when donald
trump had coveted and he was stuck in a
hospital at one point receiving
supplemental oxygen sending uh
li-laced tweets at the time
going out and exposing his secret
service detail to covid when he made
them drive him around the block in his
suv i mean just a pathetically globally
humiliating covet period for donald
trump we can't even really call it
coveted quarantine because he wasn't
properly isolating joe biden on the
other hand we already knew
had overseen and authorized the killing
of al qaeda terrorist ayman al-zawahiri
legitimate questions about the legal
framework for these killings you know
i'm right there with you but an
accomplishment by international
standards
an extraordinarily strong jobs report
late last week which we will get to
later
but the big news oh and gas prices
declining 54 days in a row and i'm kind
of kidding because as you know i don't
actually think presidents have much to
do with gas prices but by their
standards another accomplishment and now
the really really big news over the
weekend the senate approving a bill to
fight climate change and cut drug costs
not insulin unfortunately thanks to
republicans but we will get to that as
well but we are really racking up
major accomplishments here for joe biden
and it couldn't come as a better time as
democrats are surging in midterm
election polls tomorrow we will talk
about could this be one of the worst
midterms for republicans
after a democrat takes the white house
the answer is yes it could be
but we will get to that tomorrow reuters
reporting the u.s senate sunday passed a
sweeping
430 billion dollar bill
intended to fight climate change lower
drug prices
raise some corporate taxes in a major
victory for joe biden which democrats
hope will help them in november after a
marathon
27-hour weekend session of debate and
republican efforts to derail the package
the senate approved the legislation
known as the inflation reduction act by
a 51 to 50 party line vote vice
president kamal harris cast the
tie-breaking ballot this sends the
measure to the house of representatives
for a vote probably friday
they're expected to pass it send it to
the white house for joe biden's
signature
the senate is making history said an
elated senate majority leader chuck
schumer
to americans who have lost faith that
congress can do big things this bill is
for you
schumer says the legislation contains
the boldest clean energy package in
american history to fight climate change
while reducing consumer costs for energy
and some medicines
the legislation is aimed at reducing
carbon emissions and shifting consumers
to green energy cutting prescription
drug costs for the elderly and
tightening enforcement on taxes for
corporations and the wealthy the measure
pays for itself and reduces the federal
deficit over time democrats contend it
will help down uh bring down inflation
economists have generally speaking
agreed with that
from the washington post
senate approves inflation reduction act
clinching long-delayed health and
climate bill the party-line vote marks a
major achievement for democrats after
more than a year of wrangling over the
centerpiece of president biden's
economic agenda this is a really really
big deal and zoom out for a moment and
think about the last two weeks for joe
biden understanding that i am giving you
a public analysis
understanding as you and i have talked
about before
that not all of the things i'm about to
mention directly relate to joe biden
we have essentially full employment
right now more than 500 000 new jobs um
in the latest job jobs report
unemployment down to three point five
percent
this is
an extraordinary jobs report and
unemployment situation by any measure
i'm in al zawahiri major al-qaeda
terrorist killed now we might say that
was illegal okay well i'm not
disagreeing with that but from the point
of view of the accomplishments biden can
now claim in terms of saying reward
democrats in november
uh inflation reduction act with major uh
advances in a number of different areas
doing a number of good things and by the
way expected to push down inflation
which i believe tomorrow tomorrow we are
getting or no on wednesday we are
getting the july inflation numbers i
believe they are going to look much
better and i believe it is going to bump
up the market etc um and now in addition
gas prices coming down about 20 i mean
again it's sort of a joke i don't think
biden had anything to do with them going
up nor coming down
but when we say it's the economy stupid
and people look at certain indicators to
determine or things going well or not
going well
that's one of the things that they look
at now
fox news and right-wing media are
calling this bill
a social bill spending spree
as if health care is some kind of
frivolous pet project or a social issue
when it's not like it's going to be for
gay marriage or who the hell knows what
republicans are saying democrats are
going to pay the price for this bill i
don't believe that that's the case but
we will know in under three months now
one other thing
diabetics should remember when it's time
to vote and really everybody should
remember
that one of the amendments that
republican senators killed was a 35 cap
on insulin
senate republicans yesterday stripped a
proposed 35 a month cap on out-of-pocket
spending on insulin for patients
enrolled in private insurance
the senate parliamentarian earlier ruled
the provision
is not primarily related to the federal
budget so it's not eligible to be passed
by 50 votes they needed 60 votes only
seven republicans voted for it so the
insulin amendment failed
by three votes
these people are disgusting they truly
are
and we will see in november
who
this is all good or bad for let's just
leave it there
i want to talk a little bit about this
what is a woman question
because it continues to be such a major
issue for the american right wing and
over the weekend at cpac which we will
cover later on in the show
the things that got the most applause
were the most overtly
homophobic and transphobic things they
were ridiculing pronouns they were
ridiculing so-called men and women
sports and on and on and on and i want
to talk about it because it's like the
big thing that republicans now point to
as their sort of gotcha what is a woman
you won't even define it and i got a
great email from a doctor of
sociolinguistics whose name is daniel i
don't want to say more i want to protect
his identity i won't even say what
country he teaches in but daniel sent me
a ton of the information and the
research that i'm incorporating into
this story so the situation is as
follows the right loves to say you
liberals can't or won't answer the
simplest question what is a woman so you
can't be trusted with anything you're
not honest you're pathetic it's such a
simple question what is a woman just
answer it and if you won't or if you
can't then it shows how bad faith and
dishonest and radical you all on the
left are so let's start with is it
actually a simple question is the
question what is a woman simple to
answer the reality is that it's not and
now separately there are people saying
is the question even being asked in good
faith by the right and of course it's
not they're asking it to make a
political point they're asking it to
justify their pre-existing political
beliefs but let's put that aside is it a
simple question
defining common nouns is not actually a
simple thing
humans are terrible at defining common
nouns i'll give you an example define
apple without looking it up
all right well i mean without looking it
up i guess i'd say you know it's a round
fruit
whose flesh we eat and sometimes there's
red yellow or green or orangish sort of
skin
and often it's crunchy but sometimes
it's more mealy and many of them are
sweet but some of them are tart does
that really help us identify an apple
not really there's all sorts of
exceptions there's many other fruits
which fit that definition so then i can
say well an apple is
malice domestica that's the latin name
so when i say apple what i mean is
malice domestica that's just circular
that's not a usable definition i'm not
really telling you anything you can use
to determine whether something you see
is or isn't an apple
now in addition
no definition that i give you
actually encompasses all the contexts
where the word apple is used the big
apple meaning new york city taking a
bite out of the apple as a sales and
marketing term getting some market share
so the reality is that it's not unique
that with the term woman we define it
differently in different contexts the
purpose of the definition is important
what are we trying to do and i'm going
to get to that in a second and in fact
as humans and people who speak english
we can often agree on what is an apple
without a definition with
the looking at the context so the
definition itself is actually not that
important so then as daniel wrote to me
the same applies when we're trying to
define a woman what are we trying to do
by defining woman or thinking about what
a woman is and it depends on the purpose
and the context consider this
if the purpose of defining woman is that
you are a man
looking to reproduce
and you're looking for a woman with whom
you can reproduce well in that
particular
case with that purpose
a trans woman with no uterus is not a
good candidate for your purposes of
defining a woman right in that context
you're talking about an individual
with the female reproductive organs so
that you can make a baby
on the other hand if you're a man
attracted to feminine individuals by
western standards then for you it might
be quite plausible that any woman
meaning a trans woman or not who has the
female form that you're attracted to is
completely and perfectly suited to the
definition of woman that's a different
purpose it's a different context
and this is where we end up with the bad
faith republican questions about what is
a woman they want common nouns defined
so that they can either discriminate
legally
or so that it serves whatever political
purpose they want
now there's a big difference between an
apple and a woman with apples apples
can't make claims about whether they are
apples there's no sociocultural element
to apples when it comes to a noun like
woman we actually do have to pay
attention to
who claims to be a woman who is referred
to as a woman who is seen as a woman by
society in order to build up a working
understanding of what it is to be a
woman in society and culture this is all
completely normal republicans don't care
about it they don't care about
linguistics they care only about scoring
political points and putting other
people down so when they say it's so
simple you idiot leftist just what is a
woman just give us the definition well
what is the purpose of the definition
what is the context in which you were
seeking it what are you trying to then
determine with the definition this is
normal stuff
in sociolinguistics and in many other
fields they want to pretend
like it's not and it's as simple as just
what is an apple which by the way is not
actually so simple let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at
deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount
join pacman.com
well we had an absolutely blockbuster
jobs report last week we have
essentially full employment in the
united states we are down to 3.5 percent
unemployment and i have video for you of
fox news reporter maria bartoromo
praising the jobs report and it looks
like a hostage video we are going to get
to that in a moment first the numbers
u.s job growth unexpectedly soars in
july the unemployment gains far
surpassed expectations show the labor
market is not slowing despite efforts by
the federal reserve to cool the economy
the u.s employers added
528 000 jobs in july the expectation was
roughly half of that this brings the
total employment level back to its
february 2020 level remember the right
loves to say labor force participation
rate well we are now back to february
2020 remember that was trump at the time
participation rate the unemployment rate
is 3.5 percent
matching the 50-year low we have a
50-year
record low
unemployment rate at this point in time
the expectation was for 250 000 new jobs
in july 528 000 were created now what
are the counter claims from the american
right wing one of them is but some
people still lost their jobs in july yes
this happens every month you have job
creation and you have people who lose
jobs and then you have the net did you
create more jobs than were lost or not
people are losing jobs all the time the
number of jobs lost in july was tiny
secondly well what about wages well
wages are up as well
third what does joe biden have to do
with this okay you guys are already
familiar with that one so here's maria
bartoromo she has a business show she
can't really ignore the story and this
just feels like a hostage video there's
this famous video of i believe it was a
vietnam pow
who was filmed saying how well he was
being treated
but with his eyes he was blinking morse
code for torture
this seems like another one of these
hostage videos take a look at this this
is fox news and maria bartoromo visibly
pained by having to accept
the job markets looking really good
headline here this is a blockbuster
report this is much higher than anybody
was expecting 528
000 jobs created in the month of july is
more than double the expectations which
called for job growth of 250 000. all
areas of the economy actually saw job
growth including leisure hospitality the
services industry the industrial
industry that's all good news the bad
news but uh oh
how are these jobs bad for joe biden
this ensures that we are going to see a
federal reserve that stays as aggressive
as ever the markets right now are now
that's not really bad news okay the the
point is the federal reserve reacts to
what's happening in the economy she's
sort of saying like the economy is so
good that the federal reserve is going
to have to keep doing the things they do
when the economy is good
pricing in a 65
chance that the federal reserve raises
interest rates by and by the way if
they're already pricing it in
it's all okay maria let's relax another
75 basis points in the next meeting
which is in september we are waiting for
the jackson hole event which is where
federal reserve officials gather that
will be newsworthy in the coming weeks
to find out how the fed will deal with a
jobs market
so it's funny she uses a tone that
expresses significant concern but it's a
genuinely fantastic jobs report now the
economy still has all the problems that
it always has we still have high
inflation uh we still have inequality we
still have people who have to work
multiple we have all those things but
these are the standard metrics we use
and have used for at least 50 years
now what will they do tomorrow when the
new inflation report for july shows an
inflation decline that's my expectation
for uh tomorrow or wednesday i forget
which day the inflation reports coming
out how will they spin that as bad for
joe biden you know they will alright
folks this is beyond parody we now have
pictures of trump's toilet
with the flushed documents
it's beyond belief
you might remember
that during his presidency donald trump
was obsessed with toilets the only
president i can remember
this fixated on what we call the third
element of the bathroom remember this
viral moment with trump and toilets we
have a
situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers right
and other elements of bathrooms
where
you turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water when
water rushes out to sea because you
could never handle it
and you don't get any water you turn on
the faucet you don't get any water
they
take a shower and water comes dripping
out it's dripping out very
quietly quietly wet quiet water that's
not that you're not getting the water
pressure you need there now
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once
yeah and and when this this was so
bizarre
and then we learned that donald trump
would regularly flush documents down the
toilet in direct contravention to the
presidential records act he would just
flush him and then i realized this is
why trump was so concerned with the
third element of the bathroom well trump
denied that he was doing that and now we
have the pictures exclusive this is the
first time on this program i have ever
brought to you pictures of a toilet
but here are pictures
uh that axios was able to obtain and you
see a piece of paper in the toilet
uh it says rogers it says stefanik elise
stefanik is a republican congresswoman
we have it and axios reports remember
our toilet scoop earlier this year
maggie haberman's forthcoming book about
trump will report that the white house
staff periodically found wads of paper
clogging a toilet and believe trump was
the flusher
it turns out there are photos published
for the first time
haberman obtained the photos recently
shared them with axios ahead of their uh
the release of her book a trump white
house source tells her the photo on the
left shows a commode in the white house
the photo on the right is from an
overseas trip folks trump was using
foreign plumbing to dispose of these
massive dumps of notes
this is an unbelievable situation it is
2022
and we now have toilet pictures proving
that donald trump was indeed flushing
notes down the toilet maybe explaining
why he was so displeased with the
suction level
of
the toilets
at the white house
i i don't know guy i think i might have
to retire
i genuinely don't what is the point of
me continuing to do the show
after a story like this
um but this is where we are and as usual
the narrative continues to be
story comes out trump denies it then
there are pictures then there's a phone
call then there's proof that goes above
and beyond
i i don't even i feel it only
diminishes the story
if i say more
it sort of needs to be a presented
without further comment type of thing so
i will leave it there
if you want to see
the proof
make sure you're following us on
instagram
david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show all right let's talk about cpac
texas 2022 it seems like every three
weeks it's cpac it's actually not but it
was this weekend the conservative
political action conference donald trump
spoke at the event donald trump brought
up an anti-trans swimmer
trump tried to kiss the woman and she
rejected him this is one of the absolute
cringiest moments of the entire speech
donald trump calls swimmer riley gaines
up to the stage to have her say some
transphobic things transphobia was the
most reliable applause generally
generating theme at cpac when trump
tries to kiss her she flinches and she
pulls away it is absolutely beyond
parody let's take a look crazy it was
the largest applause i've ever heard
come on up here look at this
look at this
trump going in for the kiss there and
riley gaines coming in out of nowhere
and completely rejecting donald trump a
very very bizarre moment then donald
trump again spoke about his former dr
ronnie jackson now a sort of coveted
conspiracy
congressman and trump uh uh waxed poetic
about when ronnie jackson would look at
trump's body and be just impressed with
it ronnie jackson my doctor
background where's ron
where's
he was the white house doctor he was a
great doctor you know he was a admiral a
doctor and now he's a congressman i said
which is the best have you had your
choice
and he sort of indicated doctor because
he loved looking at my body it was so
strong powerful
but he said i'm the healthiest president
that's ever lived
i was the healthiest i i said i like
this guy i don't know who the hell he is
at the time i said but
so yeah i mean this entire healthiest
president thing it's so stupid first
because ronnie jackson didn't examine
every president like you know it's
totally conceivable that uh teddy
roosevelt was healthier than trump but
also trump is very clearly not healthier
than the person he
followed barack obama so it's just very
very strange stuff trump then blamed
high energy prices on the green new deal
which he wants abolished the only
problem is there is no green new deal
to bring down energy prices
we have to abolish
the green new deal
the fake it's effect
it's fake that it exists because there
has been no new uh bill signed into law
that could even remotely be called a
green new deal there are a few elements
in what was signed the day after this
speech the inflation reduction act that
overlap with some of the proposals in
the green new deal but i guess a
non-existent bill is responsible for
high gas prices around the world
donald trump then do you i don't know if
you guys have ever heard the phrase
it's a joke the phrase is i accidentally
the whole thing
and of course the joke is
you accidentally what the whole thing
like there's a missing word trump does
the exact same thing here saying two
years ago we had the greatest
in our nation unclear if it's another
one of his famous neurological glitches
if he lost his train of thought if the
teleprompter glitched who knows
two years ago we had the greatest
in our nation
what on earth we had something that was
so incredible we had the greatest people
in our nation fight there it is
uh very very trump even confused by the
speech on the prompter not a lot of
applause there uh however there was a
lot of applause when donald trump
mentioned abolishing the department of
education i would bet no one in the
crowd has any idea what the department
of education does political material to
america's school children in any form
whatsoever
and the federal bureaucrats are going to
push this radicalism we should abolish
the department of education
the crowd goes wild but has absolutely
no idea what's going on
um remember when liberals were
supposedly going to put people in camps
obama wanted to put people in fema camps
and globalist yeah you know all that
alex jones type stuff
trump repeats his plan for literally
moving homeless people forcibly into
um tent camps in uh outskirts rural
areas all of a sudden that'll stop very
quickly the only way you're going to
remove the homeless encampments and
reclaim our downtowns
is to open up large parcels large tracks
of relatively inexpensive land on the
outer skirts of the various cities
and bring in medical professionals
psychiatrists
psychologists
and drug rehab specialists and create
10 cities you have to have it they have
tents right now they're living in tents
with holes in them
you don't have time right to build
buildings
you can do that later but you have to
get the people off the tree we have to
bring back we have to reclaim our cities
and now you'll have so there it is
officially saying we will put them in a
tent camp
and that'll be it donald trump then
apparently confused about the fact that
unemployment is literally at a 50-year
low and the latest jobs report saw twice
as many jobs as expected created donald
trump saying the job situation is really
bad in american history that's why we
had the job numbers and don't forget you
have not good job numbers right now
they're not counting all of the millions
of people that aren't working
if you looked at the real numbers that
3.5 would be double that maybe some
people say triple that right of course
that's always been the case people who
are not looking for work
and are not working
are not part of the unemployment rate
that was the case under donald trump
when donald trump bragged about the low
unemployment rate these people are
morons but the bigger morons are the
people in the audience who fall for
these stupid talking points this has
always been the case uh donald trump
then also said some friend of his paid
eight bucks a gallon for gas
dubious because trump claims to have a
friend that's really the part that's not
believable have it now at five dollars
six dollars seven dollars a friend of
mine from california called me
this morning
he just paid 8.55 cents he told me
california and you'll follow yeah now uh
the truth is of course
that uh gas prices have been declining
uh dramatically now more than 20 percent
have gone from over five dollars a
gallon to four dollars a gallon 54
consecutive days of gas price declines
and even if you look at california
california certainly higher than the
rest of the country at 5
44
per gallon so continued lies from donald
trump at cpac let's now go to our
interviews at cpac so
cpac texas 2022 our correspondent luke
beasley was down there speaking to
people and it is absolutely
extraordinary now you can find luke's
youtube channel at davidpakman.com luke
to our podcast listeners you can also
find luke's audio podcast anywhere that
you are listening
i'm just going to present these to you
without too much introduction just a lot
of visible confusion
people who don't understand anything
people who don't know anything let's
take a look
and what do you think
the biggest failures of the bind
administration have been
oh gosh a lot
well
these pauses have not been extended for
effect just so everybody knows he says
that he has done things when he hasn't
such has contributed to
border security
i think for one thing
you know our president is biden but i
you know
there are other people who are actually
running our country not him
now i would at this point i would love
to say who
and i think that
a big thing
he said when he was running that he
wouldn't defund the police and he's done
that joe biden has not defunded the
police
and i think that's a huge reason why we
so see so much crime today i think that
biden has defunded the police where
well i mean he hasn't defunded them but
he's def oh so the thing you just said
isn't true god did a lot of the police
he hasn't defunded the police he's
defunded a lot of the police no also not
true and because that is done on a
city-wide level not the national level
that's true that's true um but i mean
overall i think that
this is the scariest times that we have
lived in
all right well the one thing i mentioned
you're right it's not true but it's very
very scary right now regardless um then
luke interviewed you know another guy
let's listen uh who was a standout so
far and speakers uh i enjoyed quite a
few of the speakers so
you know
i mean ted cruz was certainly animated
yep we'll get to ted cruz in a moment
some some of the speakers i didn't
actually know but you know a lot of good
information
you know those types of things really
learned a lot
and uh obviously trump is about to speak
this evening
on that topic do you want him to run in
2024
uh i i would expect him to run you know
whether it's trump or desantis you know
somebody that cares about our country is
you can tell trump deeply cares about
the future of the country that's his top
priority in all things that he does i
needed you know trump has stood in front
of the
the buzz saw that's been hitting our
country so we we do all our respects for
that he survived nancy pelosi's buzz saw
gratitude you know if he's going to
continue doing it and wins the
nomination i'll certainly support him
yeah
so i mean kind of lukewarm in a sense
support for trump this next one i'm not
going to play the whole thing because it
just it goes nowhere but it really just
shows you
like these people just have no idea
what's going on i don't understand how
they can even work a normal job and and
not get fired and who have been some
standout speakers from your perspective
um
lauren bobert i don't know if i'm saying
kind of a congresswoman obviously i love
marjory taylor green obviously um
nigel farage obviously he's always great
he's always a great asset to cpac
getting the british voice in there um
the british conservative voice so you
mentioned that you
enjoyed marjorie taylor green and you
like her um
nail down for me because it always
baffles me what is it that resonates
with conservatives about marjorie taylor
green
i think that she just um
just is not afraid of speaking the truth
and not afraid of being politically um
quote unquote incorrect marjorie taylor
green is one of the biggest liars out
there she invented the idea of that
there's a jewish space laser out there
she tells lies about vaccines she tells
lies about masks she tells lies about
joe biden she does lies about communism
she tells lies about everything what she
says is right i mean do i agree with
every single thing i nobody's black and
white everybody has areas of gray in
life life is gray
but i do think that her courage and most
republicans i hate to say this but most
republicans who've been in
the kind of in the fold for all these
decades and decades in politics they
kind of just
tout the same thing and they're full of
bull
no on my life
they're full of
they're just sitting on their you know
in their golden parachute they're
sitting in the golden parachute which is
really incredible all right so anyway
she kind of fumbled around for four
minutes then luke spoke to a younger guy
and it was
it was just as bad okay so we're outside
cpac and you're about to walk in who are
you hoping to see or who are you most
excited for i am excited to see trump
for one for two i also i'm excited to
see steve bannon
steve bannon
yeah
wow okay since you brought him up this
wasn't uh steve bannon
was pardoned by trump right what he was
pardoned for was defrauding
um like donors because he was saying i'm
building a border wall wall and he
wasn't actually doing that he was uh
spending on like personal stuff that's
why i trump had to depart him i don't
understand because there's so many
people within the conservative movement
that i understand why you'd support them
they believe your things but they like
directly
defrauded the people that they now are
uh hoping to support them like how do
you forgive steve bannon for that
you know i still just listened to his
his podcast yeah i mean on his podcast
he didn't mention defrauding people he's
my mother and i just really like the way
he speaks about issues and i think he
brings up good points regarding
politics for one
generally based on what you've heard
from the january 6 committee what is
your sense of it and do any of those
facts make you less
positive towards trump well actually my
mother attended
the january 6th and it's bad people are
still locked up over it
my family actually got investigated by
the fbi for that
and they were just attending they had
nothing to do with they were completely
innocent going into the capital right so
anyway there's a guy whose family went
to the riots
and then here's one more guy who also
did the people they just seem perplexed
so i hear most people feel like even a
lot of liberals blame biden for gas
prices going high up
now we've seen two months of pretty
historically fast drops in gas prices do
you feel like it's something you should
give biden credit for uh watching them
drop
no no
no biden's responsible for gas prices
going up
he's not responsible for gas prices
coming down no i do not
i feel like he's uh he's using our
reserves
and uh
using our reserves to drop the gas
prices and uh
trying to find the word here to yeah now
gas prices have come down globally and
so that wouldn't be because of joe biden
and also the reserves really can only by
most estimates cause a drop of somewhere
between 12 and 20 cents a gallon we're
now down over a dollar so not possible
that this is the explanation
basically fluctuate them just for a
short period of time that i think
they'll end up rising right back up to
where they were
um have you kept up at all with the
january 6 committee hearings and kind of
looking into
what led gen because you think it's kind
of stupid or what yeah yeah
i just really don't see too much of a
point in it and
that's it
so
riddle me this okay if you're on the
left and you feel like biden won the
election you look
that's what the courts figured out
that's what
kind of our official processes
certified
and then you see through these
investigations that trump was doing
everything possible to try to subvert
what we would consider the rightful will
of the people based on the election
results and uh overturn the election
don't you find it pretty reasonable that
would be super scary and regardless of
if even if you were conservative you
would expect people to be against a
president who tried to reject the
election
not necessarily
with no no i wouldn't necessarily be
against that with all of the
with all the stuff behind the all the
election fraud i feel like
i think he has every right to
say that it was not a fair election
even though all the court cases didn't
find that
yes i do
you think it
yeah i think it's a little bit corrupt
and i think our government's a little
bit corrupt and i think
yeah even those trump appointed judges
covered it up which is really really
crazy so
unfortunately more of the same and
remember everybody is allowed to vote in
the united states and at least some of
these people vote presumably
um so scary stuff and nice job there by
luke beasley you can find his youtube
channel at davidpakman.com luke make
sure you're subscribed all right before
we move off of cpac for the day just a
couple other little highlights from
other speakers at cpac texas 2022 of
course mike pillow
uh my pillow ceo mike lindell continues
to be obsessed with machines you guys
remember his obsession with machines
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines he made the
principled and defiant and scary
announcement at cpac that 54 countries
have now been taken by the machines this
is very important you hear me on this
over 54 countries have now been taken by
the machines or are getting shaken by
the machines yeah and you never get to
go back
venezuela australia they're gone
australia does not use voting machines
by the way don't get to vote out the
machines once they're there once they're
there you don't get your country back so
as you can imagine obviously i now have
that on my sound board as well over 54
countries have now been taken by the
machines yep here's ted cruz uh texas
republican senator ted cruz he now has
this pronoun quip that he uses at every
opportunity
and the crowd loves it but he just
sounds so dumb
well my name is ted cruz and my pronouns
are kiss my ass
whoa
that counts as clever and interesting
for the american right here is rick
scott rick scott who's a republican
senator of florida
i challenge you
to follow what the hell rick scott is
talking about here this is bonkers stuff
everyone will obey and no one will be
allowed to complain
you do speak up boom you're going to be
canceled
canceled your views if you don't conform
with big tech
fauchi or neil young
you'll be taking off spotify youtube
facebook and twitter yep in fact i
expressed displeasure at two neil young
songs
and we're about to lose our youtube
channel it's crazy out there
the militant left in america are the
modern-day version of book burners no
[Applause]
he was expecting more applause on that
one did you see he does this pause and
you can tell
he's expecting more applause and when it
doesn't come he just waits modern day
version of book burners
yeah that's right says one guy
canceling silence and banning from the
internet is book burning
these are the most narrow-minded
intolerant people our country has ever
seen
really struggling with the applause
lines and i also didn't realize rick
scott's diction was so poor like i
didn't realize he was this bad of a
speaker
they are completely ignorant of both
world history and american history
socialism leads to two things
poverty and oppression
there's no socialism here i mean
that
that may or may not be true but the u.s
isn't a socialist country biden's not a
socialist democrats are not socialists
socialism is not a new idea
it's one of the dumbest oldest and most
discredited ideas of the 20th century
that resulted in the deaths of 100
million people
if these democrats who have no idea how
the real world works or acting like they
just invented socialism
yeah so just an electric speaker rick
scott impossible to follow and then
lastly here is marjorie taylor greene
again saying christian nationalism is a
great thing
but when i said that i'm a christian
nationalist i have nothing to be ashamed
of because that's what most americans
are we're proud of our faith
very untrue many americans are nominally
christian
but christian nationalism meaning this
inextricable
intertwined nature of christianity and
government most americans are not for
that marjorie taylor green is just flat
out wrong so an absurd absurd cpac texas
2022 will take a quick break and be back
after this with the results of the alex
jones trial
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
well we have a verdict in the um
defamation trial of infowars conspiracy
theorist alex jones and it is 49 million
dollars now how much of it can actually
be awarded per texas statutes is a
separate question how much of it can or
will be collected
by the plaintiffs
is another question but this is the
verdict regardless let's take a look at
the moment that the judge read it out
remember that there were a four million
dollars in compensatory damages and then
we now get another 45 million in
punitive damages totaling nearly 40 uh
just over 49 million dollars
question number one four million two
hundred thousand dollars
question number two
twenty million five hundred thousand
dollars
question number three
twenty million five hundred thousand
dollars
all right um
this question is addressed to my jury is
this your verdict so say
each and all of you
thank you very much
would the attorneys like to examine the
verdict
so there it is ladies and gentlemen alex
jones 49.3
million dollar verdict as the los
angeles times accurately points out
and one of the things that michael
cizzak from the associated press writes
about is what does this mean for the
larger misinformation ecosystem a social
media fueled world of election denial
coveted skepticism and other dubious
claims that alex jones helped to build
now there are many who are saying this
is a defeat for so-called free speech
but as i know many of you are aware
there is not
um
how can we put this
i am aware
that even though i have my show
and i have my microphone and in a
literal sense i can say whatever i want
i can't just say anything and expect to
be free from the consequences of that
if i were to start targeting a private
citizen imagine that i had let's take
the eggman for example the our great
caller the eggman who has been calling
in and listening for over a decade
imagine that i started
giving out the eggman's real name
and saying things about him and and
making all of these claims specifically
about him he's just a private person who
sometimes calls in and doesn't even
identify himself by his real name and it
starts causing him problems at his job
and in his life and whatever i would not
expect that if he sues me for defamation
or doxing or whatever else
that i could just say it's free speech
and that's it it would be absurd for me
to think that that would be a valid
defense now maybe the things i say are
or aren't defamatory that's a very
specific question and part of it is
whether they are true
uh but there are limits to what i can do
with my platform i have a responsibility
on the platform not to do that and so
sure when i go after roger stone as
we're about to do a public person for
things he publicly says
that's one thing
but when you start saying
the victims of a mass shooting were
actors they they didn't really die
the parents are in on it here's specific
parents who are in on it that is not
free speech and it is not even with new
law under the existing infrastructure of
defamation law and other law you're not
allowed to do that so this is not about
free speech
and there is a question
as to whether
the
doctors and the bullies and all of them
who do this for a living
are now potentially going to be in
jeopardy because of the same legal
infrastructure nothing new no new law
has been created because of the same
legal infrastructure that may bring down
alex jones it's a real question we don't
yet know the answer one other little
thing here on the alex jones verdict a
roger stone started desperately pleading
for money for alex jones after the
uh 49 million dollar verdict this was
actually um within i think it was within
within minutes
roger stone went on infowars to make an
urgent plea
send alex jones money he needs the money
or this verdict may sink infowars here's
uh here's roger stone
alex jones is a good and decent man he's
a god-fearing christian
he's done more for this movement than
perhaps anyone you can name
and right now
he needs our support
there's a place at the infowars store
where you can go just to make a
contribution if you're not in the market
for a book or one of his great products
there's a link where you can just send a
yeah you can just send money folks it's
that simple so listen
at some point
there has to be some kind of buyer
beware thing okay we talked about this
in the context of
after the 2020 election donald trump
started
asking for money and he claimed that the
reason he was asking for money was that
he was going to fund audits and he was
going to overturn results and file
lawsuits and all these different things
and it actually said in the fine print
hey you know 50 cents on the dollar or
in some cases even more than that
actually goes to paying off trump
campaign debt or into the coffers or
however whatever the language was that
they were using there
um
and then people donated and there was
one rich guy who donated i don't
remember if it was 200 000 or 2 million
dollars and then he sued and he wanted
the money back he said he got scammed
and i don't even know what the outcome
of the case was at this point if after
all this
you go and you donate to alex jones now
at some point you've got to be sol right
s out of luck if you understand what i'm
saying
um at some point i mean if you even just
go to his website and you see the stuff
that's being sold
seed centers and survival accessories
and
various
brain food and
strange stuff
at a certain point
when you see that
legally the stuff alex jones says is
wrong and defamatory
even if you believe the system is
against him or whatever
wouldn't you have to be smart enough to
realize that if that's the case maybe it
doesn't make sense for you to be
donating money maybe you don't have to
be part of the cause of paying this 49
million settlement now the other thing i
think that bears repeating is the
following
in texas there are limits
to damages
and so the award
may get dramatically reduced imagine if
the award gets reduced to 5 million
and alex jones raises 20 because people
think he really has to pay 49 and then
he just keeps the cat i mean it's not
when your fan base is the people in the
alex jones fan base
it's not completely beyond me that alex
jones might be able to turn this into a
money-making endeavor i i'm not saying
i'm confident that will happen but it's
not completely inconceivable
unbelievable stuff
we all have a responsibility when we're
on the air
and i actually think about what i'm
saying and when i make a mistake
i make every effort to correct it and i
don't target private citizens and all
these different things
um there have to be some limits and it
seems as though alex jones has come up
against those limits
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p here's kind of a weird
question about my plastic surgery
background take a listen to this hi
david so you're like a media tv type
person okay i assume you've had a nose
job
i'm thinking about getting a nose job as
well i have some issues with breathing i
have
nasal valve collapse
it doesn't happen all the time
but
sometimes at night i can't breathe out
of my left nostril that typically
happens
um i'm just wondering like what your
opinions are
on uh
a uh just like a functional surgery like
that just to fix the nasal collapse like
should i do that or the other thing is
i'm like way overweight so like if i
lose weight i might not have the same
issues and then i've heard about like
knewing you can do like exercises to oh
my god okay so there's a lot going on
there listen you've got to talk
to an otolaryngologist also known as an
ear nose and throat doctor
i have not had a nose job
listen if i went and got a nose job do
you think this is the nose i'd be asking
for that does not seem uh that does not
seem appropriate no i have not had a
nose job um
maybe you have a deviated septum who
knows but my specialty is podiatry not
ent stuff so you've actually got to go
and talk to a doctor i don't know how
much of this voicemail is serious but i
know many people
who
have had
uh corrective nose surgeries
mostly deviated septums
it was quite a recovery took several
weeks if not into a couple of months and
yes i am aware
that sometimes
people who
have a deviated septum will say you know
what i think i'm actually going to get a
nose job and the plastic surgeon can
correct the deviated septum while
they're in there might as well do both
at once but that is not medical advice
i'm not bill o'reilly okay
i don't have a concierge service where i
give you all sorts of advice we have a
fantastic bonus show today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad you know i can think
of no greater endorsement of the bonus
show than the fact that alex jones
really doesn't like it indiana lawmakers
have approved the first state abortion
ban since roe v wade was overturned
it's happening
it's happening
u.s automakers say that 70 percent of
electric vehicle models would not
qualify for the tax credit currently in
the senate bill why not
i will explain and thirdly new zealand
is considering changing its name
to confront its troubled
colonial past hmm
have they gone woke
we will talk about it on today's bonus
show you can sign up at joinpakman.com
and get instant access
the normal prices for membership are
really low and listen
so many of us
spend 40 80 120 200 if you add up
internet service
netflix some people have cable some
people have hulu discovery plus
paramount plus apple tv all these
different things some people spend over
two hundred dollars
with the coupon code obama
you can get a membership for two bucks a
month
and you're really supporting us directly
if you have a cable subscription
something like four bucks a month goes
to fox news
you might hate fox news
okay
with the memberships on our website from
every dollar we get 98 cents the other
two cents just goes to processing the
payments okay
joinpakman.com
very cheap
great perks and you are really
you are sure you are confident that the
money is actually going where you are
being told it is going which is into
producing shows and more content
speaking of more content soon i will
tell you about the new personal finance
channel that we we are launching which i
think is going to be absolutely
tremendous folks alright see you on the
bonus show or otherwise back here
tomorrow